the Joe Rogan experience I'd be really
happy to eat your [ __ ] % want to take
a bite out of your dick person they're
[ __ ] killers yeah we're gonna say
about the Oscars though oh I was
thinking of The Killers no I was
thinking like when are we no one it's no
one can possibly see all the movies
because we keep adding to the library
every week new movies come out they
don't take movies away no you have to
hit a certain period where they're gonna
preview that movie so you up for the
awards and that's not what I mean I
don't care about the Oscars I don't get
with your awards I'm saying the number
of movies that we produce as the human
race is [ __ ] crazy and it's
never-ending yes
like every year they put out more and
movies don't go away so they're just the
database just stacking and stacking and
stacked enough to follow and it's only
been happening for a hundred years
yeah I mean and that was silent in the
beginning right so there's been a
hundred years of these movies just
stacking up and all the premises like if
you think about premises like the prole
the robots get smart and they want to
kill the people okay oh the monkeys get
smart they want to kill the people okay
like there's all these premises that
just go all those worms they live on the
ground that calls earthquakes I like it
great movie like this is so many of
these I'm in immediately so many like
like it's must be so hard to come up
with an original premise for a movie
there's so many [ __ ] movies I do you
think it's hard to come up with a new
joke or a new premise for a joke well
the way think movies what do you think
you get like Jim re-creation of Jumanji
of rocky and Predator like they're
running out of ideas
I'm a buddy buddy movies can we see can
we put the rock Kevin Hearne so I'm a
goddamn movie that's just these
regurgitation of all the same [ __ ] we've
already seen yeah yeah it's there's so
many movies yet there's not that many
paid actors is there like it's a
struggle City less than one percent make
a living acting but there's a jillion
movies is it less than one percent less
less than one percent make a living
remaking movies of all actors yes wow
that's crazy like a quality living of
all the actors less than one percent
that's pretty crazy crazy think how many
comics make a legit living do you make
comics are the difference being that for
a comic it's more
up to them correct it's more up to them
to go and you're a good piece of proof
of that obviously you have the boost of
being famous from the UFC and then being
famous from your podcast those two
things helped you as a boost but also
the hustling yeah and that's the thing
that like an actor can hustle but you
have to be hired you got to be hired to
do something there's a million moving
pieces
you gotta track well you have tests well
people have to like you'd be right for
the Royal you could just go up on a
showcase night and do like 15 minutes
and kill and you're on the money yeah
acting too [ __ ] a hard gig to
get good at too you know acting yeah I
think like God to get good at like
Daniel day-lewis Styles watching there
will be blood the other day and I was
just thinking like this guy's like the
butcher putting out so many yeah whoo
New York what does that hangs in the air
I forgot how good there will be blood
was I watched it the other day in a
hotel and I was near where it happened
because I was doing gigs in Fresno and
Bakersfield and I didn't know that but
that Tehachapi Mountains that's where
there will be blood saw about that's
where they were drilling for oil that's
right over there amazing movie dude I
think it's funny sometimes fighters
whoever athletes go I'm gonna go to
Hollywood get into acting like Matt you
need to sit in on a class or you need to
watch someone do like a dramatic role
and see if it's for you man I mean
you're talking about it's a legit craft
man some people are just good at this
there's a thing that they're doing where
you're you you're compelled by their
words you have upheld by what they're
doing it's not easy to give it's not
easy to achieve that spot not a lot of
guys do it no it's a true art that
that's why it's so tough to get casted
in those roles and TV and movies yeah
reason why it's so goddamn tough
[Applause]